today i'm gonna turn these cacao pods
into the freshest bar of chocolate
you've ever seen
and then my friend luke's gonna turn
that chocolate bar back into a cacao pot
that tastes even better than the
original
i don't think anyone's ever done this
before to start let's cut this bad boy
open
i'm always so surprised that this is
where chocolate comes from
inside are fleshy fruit covered seeds
the gooey flesh of these seeds tastes a
lot like a tropical lemonade
almost sort of like starbursts or jolly
ranchers but it's really hard to
describe and they're really gooey and
squishy
take a listen
our next step is going to be to ferment
these beans which will take about a week
this part of the process really helps to
develop all that flavor that we know and
love
in chocolate now that the seeds have
fermented you can see that the color has
changed quite a bit
they start to get almost this dark
reddish color and that means we're ready
to roast
now that we've roasted them listen to
these seeds
you can see at this point that they've
all turned this dark roasted golden
brown color almost like a coffee bean
and here's my favorite part when i crack
it in my hand
out of this seed will come cacao nibs
you're gonna have to give me a little
while here cause i'm gonna be crushing a
million cacao seeds to get out those
nibs
you might recognize these cacao nibs
from the top of a smoothie bowl or from
a fancy cafe somewhere they're a little
bit bitter but this is basically the
only ingredient that you need to make
chocolate
i'm going to add my cacao nibs to a
grinder i'm going to start grinding this
and at first it'll turn into a powder
but then once that cocoa butter is
released it'll turn into a chocolate
paste
i can add just a little bit of sugar
into my chocolate and once i mix that up
this right here will taste just like a
chocolate bar
next i'm going to temper the chocolate
and to start i'll pour about 60
of my cocoa powder into a bowl over a
double boiler
i want to get this melted chocolate up
to about 114 degrees fahrenheit
once my instant read thermometer reads
114 fahrenheit i'll pour in the
remaining 40
and stir this until it hits 91 degrees
fahrenheit tempering chocolate can
definitely be tricky but if you do
follow along with just a couple simple
steps
and have a reliable thermometer to work
with it's actually not too difficult now
that we're at 91 fahrenheit
let's pour this into our molds spread
that chocolate out as evenly as possible
and then we wait cool that sounds fun
that's amazing oh
now we'll let that chocolate rest for
about a half an hour until it's well
tempered
and now with all this leftover chocolate
i get to do the best part
lick the spoon after letting this temper
we have our chocolate bar
this part on the bottom right here is
smooth as a baby's bottom
which tells me that we did a really good
job tempering but the more important
part is the other side the part we're
actually going to look at
i'm gently going to peel back the mold
which will expose this perfect
chocolate bar you have to admit it's
pretty crazy that we just took a cacao
pod and turned
it into this now i'm gonna pack up my
chocolate bars with a little bit of
aluminum foil
and send them off to my buddy luke who's
gonna work with magic
all right let's see what we got from
nick here
oh willy wonka in the house
[Music]
all right i can work with this all right
so now we're gonna benjamin button this
thing
back into cacao pod got my double boiler
here chocolate from nick
break them up just give these some time
so i'm gonna need a couple more
ingredients to make the actual cacao pod
flour sugar baking soda and baking
powder
cocoa powder just for a little extra
flavor mix
this up milk vegetable oil vanilla
extract two eggs here
gonna mix that up now the best part
we're adding
nyx chocolate and then we'll just mix
this together
one cup of water super super moist
all right here we go so we're gonna bake
this in the oven
at 350 for a half hour so i'm going to
start by carving all the crusts off
level out the top so soft and this part
is pretty fun
okay i'm trying to carve the general
shape at least
fill it with some chocolate buttercream
top it off with this guy and then just
gonna let it cool in the fridge a little
bit
already just gonna jump in here start
carving down to our
cacao pot so i'm starting on the top
and just going down kind of like a
football
all right so now i'm just going to go
ahead and do the indents that run down
the side
so this is just the layer of buttercream
that the fondant will stick to
[Music]
smooth it out super handy dandy
note card carving away at the
buttercream so i have my modeling
chocolate here and i twist it
kind of push them along okay a little
bit of cornstarch
all right so our cake is all firm cover
this in our
modeling chocolate make sure it's really
stuck to our buttercream
pulling and pleating closed up along the
bottom
get all those creases in to our butt
here
gonna texture it right before going into
the airbrush so i'm gonna start by doing
a very light layer of
yellow and this really kind of pushes
the color
all around too now we got some orange
going on
so with the brown i'm gonna go into each
like visible
indentation that i see let's paint this
but
brown food dye and green alcohol the
green alcohol is gonna make it
dry really fast so i don't have to worry
about anything smudging like i
did with the airbrush and water and just
splatter all over the cake just like the
cacao pod
now i'm just gonna go along and do like
the bigger splatters
and blemishes all right and there you go
what do you think are you kidding me
that looks insane
i couldn't have done it without your
beautiful cacao nibs man
i really really wish i could taste that
right now all right what do you say we
cut this guy
let's cut right into that bad boy
wow here's the reveal oh
sweet cheers
that's delicious it really is
[Music]
you